はぁぁ
もう農業ばやめようと思うとたいっ
この一言が始まりでした
近年増え続ける
野生動物の以外になすすべなく農業諦めている人がこんなに近くにいうことを
花農家の私は知りませんでした
ハウスで花を栽培する腹農家は野生動物の被害とは無縁です
ただこんなに視覚で困っている人がいるよええ
なんとかしてあげたいそう思いますよね
皆さんはこんな経験ないですよ
自分が得することなんてひとつもないそう分かっている
でも何とか自分ができることをして差し上げたい
そしたら
大きなありとなって返ってくる
これを
繊維氷と呼びます yeah
今日は先義後利のアイデアを私の経験をもとにみなさんにお話ししたいと思います
まず私の3つのかを紹介させてください
一つは3代目の農家としての
palmer
そして
インターネットを使いこなす妻は農家
猪向き合う農家ハンターです
私は
大学を卒業後2年間アメリカは c 今バレーにある世界一の3農家で
あのからの勉強させていただいて
25歳の時に戸馳島に入っていました
花農家になって毎日生き物と向き合うことに喜びややりがいを感じながらも
お客さんと私た頃の間に大きな壁があることに少しの不安を覚えました
そんな時にシリコンバレーで感じてくださいん
そして学生時代に
北海道の農家の医者が教えてくれた言葉が蘇ってきちゃうんです
矢野宣
これからの時代の農業大切な農具
それはパソコンだっ
それを経営に使うのは今や当たり前
と息を使って情報発信をしていければ田舎なんか関係なくなるぞ
絶対これからは農業の時代だそ
そうだっ
私は思い切って再万能型を登り始めました
2007年州などの結構気にん
新しいチャレンジをしよう
2人でネットショップを始めました
お店の名前は森瑞季です
これは私の妻の本名です
花屋に切ったりの名前ですよねー
この美しい名前を何とか残したいなと思ってお店の名前を守りに好きのラン屋さんとし
ました
きっと売れるに違いないわくわくしたから始めてはみたものの
2年間まったく売れませんでした
でもあきらめずに続けることができましたなぜか
それはお客様から入る
ありがとうや喜びの声が大きな支えになってたんです
インターネットを通じて
ありがとうの声が聞こえろ新しい時代の農業が来たと思いました
そして2009年私たちに待望の赤ちゃんが誕生しました
うれしさはって言っ
すっぴんの花所の写真をメールマガジンで紹介しました
長期客の名前は元気誕生祭
私たちお父さんとお母さんになりました
幸せのおすそわけ政府
話の癪だったんですか
たくさん拡散されて当時売り上げが十数万円でた
裂傷がなんと一気に数十倍にもまたです
インターネットても喫したイメージありますよね
私たちはそこに自分たちの喜びは顔を出すことによって温度感を持たせ
きっとそれが共感されなんだと思っています
もうワクワクしてワクワクして毎日仕事が楽しくてしょうがなかったです
そして迎えた2012年母の日
5秒間に1軒という驚異的な注文が集まっていました
結果
目標の5倍んとなる8日間で5000万円もの売り上げをあげることができるのです
でもほどと来たるも知らない私はもっとベルぞ
もっと行こう
出荷キャパを終えて
振り続けました
その結果
心も体もボロボロになったうえお客様にも迷惑をかけてしまいました
クレーム対応が終わってようやく2週間
朝から心臓が以上気がしました
なんとか倒れた上であ
ad をしていただくことができ
一命を取り留めることができました
全身麻酔から覚めていく中ねー
2人目の子供を宿し
飛行協議会ている妻うことが重いから涙が出てきました
私は人生をかけていたいものは本当にお金だけなのか
今日が最後だとしてもお金を求めていくのかあっ
そんな時に
はっきり分かりましたいや違う
そこで出会ったことからこの戦以降位でした
咲美人や地域の役に立つことをしていれば必ず帰ってくる
そういう先人の教えです
簡単聞こえますが多くの大人たちはこうです
いつか成功したら後から社会貢献でもしようかなっ
本当にできますかああ
棺桶に入る前になったときに
あーあんなこともしたくなかった
子どもたちともっと時間を過ごしているが良かった
そんな後悔絶対しないと生きれますか
私は自分が死ぬような経験をして
自分に何ができるか何が残せるか
ほうきで考えられるようになりました
思ったことは実行しなければ思わなかったことがをなしっ
私は
会社デー
東日本大震災の被災者の皆さんに募金を始めました
そして熊本自身へとツン系
今年募金総額が1000万円を超えました
微力でも無力ではない
そう信じてぐ食に続けてきた私たちに大きな氷が舞い込んできました
大手の石サイトで年間 mvp に選んでいただきました
さらには日本でいちばん大切にしたい会社と称されるようになったんです
私たちはこうして身をもって戦技講義を体験することができました
ん
私たちはこうやって自分たちがとなくの花を全国のお客さんが峠できるようになりまし
た
ただ周りを見回してみますと
周りは周りの農業は高齢化
そして担い手不足に上げています
私も何かできないかそう考え気が2016年の2月
また運命を変えるような衝撃音言葉にやりました
それは友人のご両親が営むみかん園でのことでした
おばあちゃん
もう美香のシーズンで甘噛み蒲田の色紙と言
そう言う私に思い掛けない返事が返ってきたのです
もう農業はやめようと思うとかいっ
収穫直前のミカンを位のシニフィアンされて
怖くて追い返しもできないし
また食べられると思う
もう
農業なでやめたほうがマシないっ
おばあちゃんは肩を震わせていました
自分にも何ができないか
こうした時に私は友達が多いことに改めて気づきました
ん
俺がやらねば誰がやる
今やれば1できるそんな気持ちで仲間落ちてねー
イノシシともこれからについて一晩掛け
座をくべ語り合いました
そこで
災害や火災から地域を守る消防団のように僕らは
犬 c などの獣害から地域と畑を守る
そんな離縁を掲げて熊本農家反感を立ち上げました
2016年4月震災前の日でした
車
猪活動を始めてみている
私は何じゃ一番多いかと思いましたん
それは
イノシシのカプ話をするとみんなが以上に
盛り上がるということ
お年寄りも
若者も
農業も農業の種類も
エリアを越えて
みんなが
主は本当はにくいはずなのにその話をすると笑顔なるのです
さらには産学官民
これが命というマジックワード一つで強烈に強く結びついていきます
私たちはこれを猪コミュニケーションと呼ぶことにしました
皆さんこれはご存知ですよね
猪ピースです
みなさんぜひ一緒にやってくださいか
講師ですね猪 ce と言いますの敷いてくださいね
なりますせーのいいのーしーし
車
このか者の瞬間に写真押せば皆がハッピーな写真が撮れますね
是非試してみてください
私たち農家ハンターは版たと言いながらも実は銃を使いません
山から下りてくる命さんたちから地域を守りながらやむを得ない場合の日
taka wada という罠を買ってい主をつかまえます
捕まえたいな衝動するからや前にもう一度運んで逃したとしても
農産物の味を覚えた彼らは必ずまた快適しまいます
だから私たちはこの手で彼らの命を止めなければならないんです
どうやって命を止めると思いますよ
地域と畑を守る活動というのは私たち人間の都合です
彼らの命を奪うことは本当に辛く
描く上
夢に出てくることもあります
農家がハンターとして
なっていくためにはこうした精神的なものを乗り越えながら
イノシシ対策と農業この2つを物理的に両立させていく必要があります
そこで私はサイバー農家の知見を生かした
わざとインターネットをつなぐこの iot 一の号入試は脳の見回りを劇的に減らす
ことができました
さらにこれを見てくださいこれは漁師のおじちゃんに私がアドバイスをもらっている所
の自動撮影カメラが撮影したものですがこの2日後にうり坊がたくさんつの教えます
さらにはお母さんらー
そしてさらにママ友まで来てるって言う社長です
非常に貴重ですよねでもこうして今までみえることがなかった
野生動物の姿が
はっきりと見えるようになっちゃうんです
さらには it 企業と共同で ai 乙かっぱ
イノシシを分別するようなシステムを開発してホームページや sns でっ
啓発しています
こんな花号から私が3年半
書と角をして夢中になって猪活動を先議で続けてきました
そんな私が下手郡それは
仲間です
県内各地に若手農家脳が100人も賛同し活動を始めてくれました
おかげで年間200頭もの
イノシシをつかめるようになる
no 作物の被害を随分を抑えられるようなできました
では捕まえたい主はどうするか
私は誰よりも背25りの法則を知っています
yeah
4000万円の借金をして作った
農家ハンター地 b ファームが今月末
完成します
[拍手]
そうなんですこれからが氷のです
今までせるしかなかった
よしさんを私たちはこれから最高のジビエとしている
って
そしてオーガニックなペットフードとしてさらに
なめした革はこうしてあなたな価値を生むものとして作り始めています
さらに肥料として畑に戻すことで農家ならではの
サスティナブルがモデルが出来ました
そう
今では私たちは三好市は自然の恵みバイ
そう笑って言えるようになってました
ただ農家初部のか反対活動の本登記もそれは猪退治にあらずです
この活動を
一番は苦い手作りなんです
活動を通じて若手農家が
あんたたちのおかげでまた今ば植えられなくなったよ
とか
あそこの息子はドラ息子て覚えたかったよねほんとは予告ねっ
そして地域から必要とされ人からありがとうと言われる経験によって皆の目の色が
変わってきています
こうして地域で元気が有り余っていた若手の農家たちが父の担い手と戸田キスあるの
です
最後に私たちはこのもうからいい
it 技術を駆使して命対策に乗り出し
地域の未来たになっていくこの活動を全国に広げ
花供養していただけるようにと思っています
さらに世界の人に知っていただけるように
sdc ずの活動を通じて
国連の場で
この活動を報告できることを期待しています
そうして
多くのはか某たちが世界に出て
多くの国で農業も救いヒーローとなっていく
講師得られる氷は皆さんなんだと思いますかん
きっとそれはクイントピンとの関係を超え私たちの子供の台に返ってくるものではない
かと信じています
微力でも無力ではない
何をしなければゼロのままですよ
仲間と集いみんなデー
一歩を踏み出すことによって私たちは世界を変えていけるかもしれません
今日のタイトルはいやー
私の
ウイで語れる仲間を紹介したいと思います
お父さん
先ほどくん
木村さん
西川くん
ミューザくん
井上か
森さん
たっちゃ
これが私たち農家ハンターですありがとうございました
[拍手]